NAZMUL IDRIS: Welcome
to this episode of UXD,
where we will talk
more about Lean UX
and how to measure
changes in user behavior
to determine whether your design
decisions were good or bad.
I'm your host Nazmul
Idris, a develop advocate
passionate about
design and mobile.
And I have a very special guest
with me on the show today.
LAURA KLEIN: Hi,
I'm Laura Klein.
I'm a user experience
designer who loves data.
Thanks for inviting me.
NAZMUL IDRIS: You're most
welcome, and thank you
for being here.
So Lean UX is a way
to apply the methods
of learning as
quickly as possible
and reducing the cycle
time through what's
called the build
measure, and learn loop
to the process of user
experience design.
Now, practicing Lean UX
means that you're always
validating with users, that
you're designing something
that people will actually use.
It's about designing
products that
are both usable and useful.
Laura wrote a really
good book about this
called "UX for Lean Startups."
In this episode,
we're going to talk
about qualitative and
quantitative research, what
they are, how to use them,
and most importantly, why
to use them.
So Laura, why do
developers and designers
need to know different
types research?
What's that got to do
with building products?
LAURA KLEIN: That's
an excellent question.
So research, both
qualitative and quantitative,
is the key to building
great products.
Without measuring the
results of our work
through things like
analytics, AB testing,
qualitative research, and
a host of other methods,
we really can't
understand the impact
that our changes are
having on end users.
This means that we can't do
things like make good product
choices or learned from
any mistakes we might make.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So these are just different
ways of measuring results.
So what is qualitative
research exactly?
LAURA KLEIN:
Qualitative research
is about observing and
listening to people.
So it includes things like
usability testing, customer
development interviews,
and in-context studies
where you might
observe somebody using
a product in their
natural environment.
There are tons of types
of qualitative research.
But you can tell
research is qualitative
if it involves talking
to people or observing
real human behavior.
NAZMUL IDRIS: I see.
That makes sense.
So now, these tests,
it doesn't sound
like they're statistically
significant, correct?
LAURA KLEIN: That's right.
They're not.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Oh.
So why do them?
What are they good for?
LAURA KLEIN: So they're
great for things
like understanding the
problem that you're
going to solve for
a user, or learning
the context that your product
is going to be used in.
They're also going
for building empathy
and for really understanding
the person that you're
building the product for.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Ah,
that makes sense.
So what about
quantitative research?
How is that different
than qualitative?
LAURA KLEIN: So
qualitative research
is often the preferred
method of engineers.
It includes things like
analytics, AB testing,
funnel metrics.
It's always statistically
significant,
and it never really
involves talking
to humans, which might be why
it's so beloved of engineers.
But quantitative research,
as the name implies,
is all about the data.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That make sense.
So I get to pick whichever
one I like, right?
LAURA KLEIN: No.
Sadly, you do not.
See, qual and quant do
really different things
about both your user
and your product.
As a general rule,
quantitative research
tells you exactly what is
happening with your product,
while qualitative research
tells you why it's happening.
So quant is what, qual is why.
If you use both
of these together,
you get an enormous
amount of information
about both your
product and your users.
And you can come up
with some great ideas
about how to make it better.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
That's really cool.
So can you give me an example
of how they work together?
LAURA KLEIN: Yeah.
So let's imagine that
you have a product
and you're actually
charging people to use it.
NAZMUL IDRIS: What?
LAURA KLEIN: I know.
Crazy, but I thought
you might like it.
So at some point, you need
to actually put people
through a checkout
flow of some sort.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Ah.
So you mean getting their
payment information, shipping
and billing address, and so on?
LAURA KLEIN: Exactly.
So you can visualize your
checkout flow as a funnel.
Let's imagine that this
particular flow requires
all sorts of things,
that it requires people
to create an account,
select the plan they want,
enter their credit card
and address information,
confirm their purchase.
And then the final screen
is the thank you screen.
So you want to measure not
just how many people make it
way through to the
thank you screen.
You also want to
measure the drop off
at each step of the funnel.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Why is that?
LAURA KLEIN: Well, it gives
you more detailed information
about where people
are getting stuck.
See, picture that funnel.
100% of the people who want to
buy your product or think they
want to buy your product
start at the first step.
And then let's say
you lose 20% there.
Then maybe you lose
10% at the next step.
And then 50% of the
remaining people drop
off at the next step, and then
maybe a third on the last step.
That means that only a small
percentage of the people who
started at the top
are actually getting
to the bottom of the funnel.
So if you start with
100 people, then you've
got 80, and then 72, and
then 36, and then 24.
And suddenly, only 24
people are actually
making it through to the end
and paying you for your product.
But the nice thing about
knowing how many people you
lose at each step is that
you can use that information
to decide which step to
make changes to in order
to best increase
the number of people
who make all the way to the end.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Ah, I see.
So you might want to make
some changes, in this case,
to step three, where you're
losing 50% of the people.
LAURA KLEIN: That's right.
That's clearly a friction point.
But of course, at
this point, we just
know that people are
dropping off there.
We don't know why yet.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Can we just guess?
LAURA KLEIN: Well, we could.
But our guesses
would be a lot better
if we did some observational
user research to understand
whether there's a
specific problem
that people are
having on that step.
So for example, maybe there's
something really confusing.
Or maybe there's
some information
that people don't have
available to them on that step.
Or maybe the page just loads
really slowly for some people.
By observing five
or six people going
through that whole
checkout flow,
you can start to make some much
better guesses about what you'd
want to fix on that step three.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So now let's say we know
what the problem is.
What do we do then?
LAURA KLEIN: Well,
then you fix it.
Of course, if it involves
big changes to that step
or to the rest of
the flow, you want
to do some qualitative
usability research
while you're designing it.
That can help make sure
that your next version
of the checkout flow doesn't
introduce new usability
problems.
So when you're
pretty sure you've
got a good change to the
product, you build it
and you ship.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
LAURA KLEIN: But that's
not the end, of course.
You still need to release
the fix it and AB test.
So AB testing is another form
of quantitative research.
This means that we can
validate that we've really
fixed the problem
that we had, and we
haven't introduced new ones.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Oh, I see.
So this way, we've
identified what
the problem is with
quantitative research.
LAURA KLEIN: Mmhm.
NAZMUL IDRIS: And
then we've got an idea
of why the problem is
happening with qualitative.
But then we actually then
use qualitative research
to help design the
change and then confirm
that we fixed it with
quantitative again?
LAURA KLEIN: Exactly.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Wow, that's cool.
That makes sense.
So I'm going to play
devil's advocate now.
So I've heard that
it's not worth it
to do qualitative research,
because users really
don't know what they want.
So asking them is useless.
Is that true?
LAURA KLEIN: Well,
I've heard that too.
And it's a fundamental
misunderstanding
of how to do good
qualitative user research.
So let's be totally clear.
If you're just asking
people what you should build
and then going and
building it, you're
probably not going to
make a very good product.
That 100% true.
But to be fair,
you're not actually
doing good qualitative research.
You're just outsourcing your
entire product development
process to your users.
And you know what?
They're probably not great at
designing fantastic products.
That's your job.
You're supposed to be
designing the product.
So if you learn good quality
user research skills,
you're going to be able to learn
a huge amount from your users
without ever once
asking that question.
So what do you think
this product should do?
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So now what about the argument
that you cannot make big design
changes will AB testing
and quantitative research?
I've heard that.
I mean, I've heard a lot
of designers say that.
LAURA KLEIN: Yeah, a
lot of them do say that.
And again, it's a
complete misunderstanding,
this time of
quantitative research.
See, remember analytics,
AB testing, funnel metrics?
Those are just tools.
They're hammers.
You can test anything you
want using these tools.
The fact that you're
doing AB testing
doesn't dictate
what you can test.
I mean, you could test button
colors or 42 shades of blue
or whatever you want, all
sorts of little optimizations
like that.
But you can also test
entirely different flows
against one another.
You can test how
user's behave when
they have a new feature
against how they behave when
they don't have the new future.
AB testing isn't just
for optimization.
It's a marvelous tool for
understanding the real impact
that your design changes
are having on the end user.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Oh,
that makes sense.
So it sounds like using
quantitative and qualitative
together is more powerful than
just using each one by itself.
LAURA KLEIN: That's
exactly right.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
So that's all we
have time for today.
If you'd like to learn
more about qualitative
and quantitative
research methods,
please check out Laura's
book, "UX for Lean Startups."
It's amazing.
It has a lot of tips
and tactics for doing
the right kind of research
at the right time.
Laura, thanks again
for joining us here.
LAURA KLEIN: Oh, thanks
so much for having me.
It was my pleasure.
Go build something awesome.
NAZMUL IDRIS: And finally,
if you haven't already,
please join our UX
community on Google+.
Thanks again for
watching, and goodbye.